quand je vais vous pointe du doigt
quand je te pointe du doigt quand je
pointe du doigt la communauté le
gouvernement le corps médical en
coaching on dit j'ai aussi trois doigts
retourné vers moi quelles solutions
vais-je pouvoir trouver quelles
ressources intérieures et jean mois
telle question devrais je me posais
bonsoir je m'appelle cédric moulin et
aujourd'hui je suis venu vous apporter
un message d'espoir à travers mon vécu à
travers des expériences les expériences
de personnes dont je vous parlais dans
un instant cet espoir c'est la notion de
rebondissements face à un diagnostic
inacceptable par mon histoire un mois
elle commence avec un héritage
mon grand père clément de nef et dans la
résistance il est attrapé par la gestapo
il va passer deux ans et demi en camp de
concentration à matha aux amis il est
libéré par les américains
il revient à paris extrêmement affaibli
est également choqué de remarquer qu'à
paris le train train avait continué les
affaires avaient continué en son absence
nous a transmis beaucoup de choses des
belles choses
son amour pour la liberté pour laquelle
s'est battu pour laquelle il a souffert
la notion d'autonomie et surtout je vais
y revenir tout à l'heure la notion
d'espérance
le fait de ne pas lâcher prise le fait
de continuer à croire même quand tout
semble joué contre nous mon deuxième
grand père s'appelait jean moulin ce
n'était pas le résistant qui a donné son
nom au campus de cette université jean
moulin
mon grand père était un médecin ils
n'étaient pas résistants quoique à sa
façon peut-être
en tant que médecin il a pratiqué très
très tôt c'était un des premiers en
france à être acupuncteur homéopathe
nous a appris avec ces pratiques à lui à
nous soigner tout seul à nous soigner
entre nous en famille et puis mon père
on perd du coup là m'a transmis
l'apiculture
c'est moi sur cette photo j'ai à peu
près 15 16 ans on est en train
d'attraper un essaim j'ai beaucoup
appris de l'apiculture grâce aux
abeilles
j'ai compris leur faiblesse et leur
ville d'un bear head vulnérabilité face
aux pesticides
face aux parasites les abeilles
on en avait 15 ruches on en a plus
qu'une
elles sont en très fort déclin les
abeilles m'ont appris la patience et le
respect de l'humain de la nature de
l'insecte le respect du vivant
et puis je suis allé voir ailleurs j'ai
beaucoup bougé j'ai étudié j'ai
travaillé dans différents pays
au canada j'allais travailler en suisse
en turquie en inde en autriche
je suis même remonter en belgique où
j'habite aujourd'hui avec ma femme et
mes enfants qui sont tous les deux nés à
istanbul à l'époque où j'étais à
istanbul je travaillais pour
multinationales qui m'a appris beaucoup
de choses j'ai appris je travaillais
dans le métier de supermarché de
l'hypermarché
j'ai appris ce que la grue mais
l'agroalimentaire faisait et j'ai
commencé à me poser des questions sur ce
qu'on n'allait mettre dans les assiettes
de nos enfants j'ai commencé à
travailler à istanbul pour cette société
là en 2000 et en 2001 je commence à
recevoir des nouvelles de ma maman
véronique
en juin 2001 après dix ans de soucis de
santé
elle nous fait part de complications on
a compris qu'elle était en hyper à nîmes
où elle est en risque potentiel si un
accident de voiture
c'est là une opération qui tourne mal
elle peut y rester
elle est à un cancer du col 1 du côlon
elle nous en a pas parlé elle a attendu
d'être opéré très rapidement quelques
jours après
dès juillet le cancer s'étant déclaré
très très tard elle se fait opérer le
teich 37 kg son poids normal c 59 kg
c'est dire qu'elle avait vraiment la
peau sur les os face à sa faiblesse
suite à l'opération on lui enlève 75
centimètres d'intestins elle refuse tous
les traitements
elle refuse la chimiothérapie elle
refuse la radiothérapie qu on les
propose une alternative et tous les
matins on vient la voir dans sa chambre
nous avons alors madame oullins on peut
commencer maintenant on est traitement
et au bout de deux semaines fatigué de
dire non elle écrit une lettre de
décharge aux médecins qui la soignent
elle décide de rentrer à la maison va
soigner en tout cas elle va essayer les
médecins lui donnent six mois elle
commence une recherche obsessionnelle
une recherche sur ce qui a pu causer son
cancer qu'est-ce qu'elle s'est fait à
elle-même qu'est ce qu'elle a fait qui a
pu causer ce soucis de santé
et qu'est-ce qui est éventuellement a pu
nous arriver aussi à nous en tant
qu'enfant en tant qu en termes de
transmission
elle commence à nous envoyer des paquets
moi qui habite à istanbul ya ma soeur
qui habite à osaka toutes les deux trois
semaines on reçoit des cartons avec des
photocopies de tout ce qu'elle apprend
en termes de naturopathie en termes
d'hygiène de vie est à nous envoie aussi
des nutriments des compléments
alimentaires
rythme effréné toutes les deux trois
semaines c'est un petit peu comme son
chant du cygne
on lui a donné six mois donc il faut
qu'elle se dépêche de corriger le tir
pour nous et ma maman a survécu elle est
toujours là donc ça nous fait presque 18
ans aujourd'hui elle est plus jeune
qu'elle l'était je pense à cette époque
là en tout cas après dix ans de soucis
de santé
ma maman à l'époque était plus très très
belle à voir
et aujourd'hui et bien elle a un visage
poupon elle a des fesses de bébé
elle va très très bien il ya nous a
transmis donc de très très belles choses
elle nous a appris qu'il faut parfois
résister à la pression savoir résister à
la pression des médias des lobbys du
discours ambiant
évidemment dans son cas c'était
évidemment c'était le corps médical
essayer d'apprendre par soi même
lire lisez prenez le temps de découvrir
des auteurs d'apprendre sur vous sans
cesse jusqu'à la fin ne vous laissez pas
dicter votre conduite
c'est une expérience qui nous a beaucoup
apporté et qui évidemment servi à ma
petite famille à moi ma femme et mes
enfants qui sont là aujourd'hui vont
bien sont en très bonne santé sont très
très rarement malade personnellement en
suivant les conseils de ma maman je n'ai
pas si je n'ai pas eu de consultations
de médecins entre 98 et 2015 et on
arrive à une nouvelle personne en
janvier 2015
mon collègue coach nous présente sa
fille lucile il ya un grave problème de
santé en août 2015 lui s'il commence à
avoir des douleurs dans le bas du dos ça
fait très très mal et ça va en empirant
elle fait des tests et au bout de six
mois elle apprend qu'elle a ce qu'on
appelle une spondylarthrite ankylosante
vous savez ce que c'est la
spondylarthrite ankylosante
c'est une inflammation chronique très
grave qui provoque des douleurs
permanentes comme si on vous planter des
aiguilles dans le dos ni tes jours
lucile à 21 ans et elle marche comme une
petite dame de 110 ans avec des
béquilles douleur permanente en mars
2016 un médecin lui dit un rhumatologue
de paris lui dis bien écouté ma ptite
dame
il va falloir apprendre avec la douleur
parce que votre maladie est incurable 21
ans n'a pas de remède
alors je décide d'aider lui s'il est
bien me retrouver en belgique mois le
mois suivant on février 2017 on décide
de faire ensemble ce qu'on appelle un
on va regarder tout ce qui s'est passé
chez elle elle établit une frise de vie
et on regarde tous les événements santé
événements familiaux les déménagements
les évènements qui ont eu un impact sur
son mental et on travaille surtout ça
tout en quinconce du cil m'étonne elle
m'impressionne
elle accepte de changer toutes ses
habitudes elle nous écoute
elle nous donne un feedback permanent
elle change la nutrition elle change son
mode de vie commence à prendre des
nutriments
elle veut vraiment y croire on travaille
en coaching sur son mental sur des
événements qui ont lieu dans sa vie
jusqu en août 2010 est donc la même
année six mois après notre rencontre
on reçoit un message surréaliste elle
est venue elle et elle est partie en
vacances
elle est revenue elle a fait une heure
et demie de parcours vous savez ce que
c'est le parcours c'est une gymnastique
urbaine c'est nous vient des états unis
c'est c'est très très intenses
physiquement vous allez sauter au dessus
des bancs vous accrochés aux branches
marcher sur les murs elle fait ça
pendant une heure et demie elle se sent
bien à les plus malades sa maladie soit
disant incurable et terminer en tout cas
elle est en rémission
deux mois plus tard on reçoit un nouveau
message qui nous dit je suis enceinte du
pouvoir assouvir le rêve de ma vie
avoir un enfant lucile donne naissance à
clémence le 15 juin 2018 clément c'était
un beau bébé bien dodues qui va très
très bien
sa maman aussi va bien et d'ailleurs
elle est là parmi nous ce soir
tu peux faire signe lucile tu vas bien
si tu veux si tu va super bien
si tu te sens loin de ta douleur est ce
que tu peux lever le poing comme ça s'il
te plaît
il ya quelques semaines je tombe sur
instagram sur le compte qu'elle a créée
pour son blog la vie comme lulu et cette
image là aussi surréaliste où elle se
promène en talons aiguilles avec la
poussette de clémence quelque chose
qu'elle n'aurait pu imaginer faire il ya
seulement deux ans alors suite à ces
expériences
quelle clé je résume en quelques slides
en quelques mots ce que j'ai appris de
tout ce que je viens de vous raconter la
première notion c'est une photo que j'ai
découverte sur dans une expo à istanbul
à l'époque que j'ai reproduit puisque
gelée par trouver quelqu'un l'a écrit
sur un mur de fabrique à new york en
grosses lettres blanches en grosses
lettres blanches
il n'y a pas de certitude
quelqu'un est arrivé derrière et avait
rajouté ah bon tu es sûr donc il n'ya
pas de vérité unique
quand quelqu'un arrive et vous assène ce
genre de choses les experts les gourous
posez vous des questions remettant
remettez en question tout ce que vous
avez entendu
ne prenez rien pour argent comptant
personne vraiment personne n'a tout à
fait la science infuse et surtout les
gens qui prétendent l'avoir il n'y a pas
une seule solution dans la vie il n'ya
pas un seul remède
on a énormément de choix et c'est bien
de toujours se poser des questions
toujours considéré d'autres voies
imaginez le corps comme une table de
mixage gigantesque vous connaissez pas
tous les curseurs et pourtant ils sont
tous importants et l'idée quand on est
malade comme maman comme lui comme tout
un chacun c'est de faire remonter les
curseurs petit à petit de les identifier
les faire remonter
alors on parle de quoi on parle de
protéines peut-être lipides ça vous
savez et puis après on va plus dans le
détail les oméga-6 les oméga 3 les
vitamines les minéraux les
oligo-éléments tout compte
tout fonctionne en synergie c'est pour
ça qu'il ya pas un seul élément qui est
important tout est important en fait
c'est l' équilibre qui compte on va
regarder aussi évidemment les métaux
lourds on en parle avec cette notion de
deux vaccins lévy aluminium les métaux
lourds qui viennent nous toxi fier
comment est ce qu'on fait pour nettoyer
ça qu'elle ait l'air qu'on respire
aujourd'hui quelle est la qualité de
l'air on mange trois fois par jour et
vous respirez en permanence on boit de
l'eau quelle est la qualité de l'eau
tout ça ce sont des détails c'est de la
minutie et c'est super important de
travailler ensemble là dessus alors
cette notion d'espérance que mon grand
père m'a apprise qui est reprise par
l'auteur français charles péguy qu'il
appelait la petite vertu
c'est cette fameuse lumière intérieure
qui fait qu'on ne va pas laisser tomber
on va continuer à se battre et cette
lumière elle se travaille
ce travail par plein de choses chacun à
sa façon la méditation le sport la
reconnexion à la nature les repas sympa
en famille les vacances
la lecture est vraiment indispensable et
puis il ya cette notion de bienveillance
aujourd'hui la planète est dans une
situation compliquée on vit une crise de
civilisation et mon petit doigt me dit
que s'il y avait plus de bienveillance
déjà nous mêmes par rapport à nous mêmes
se pardonner accepter nos erreurs
essayer d'apprendre donner aux autres la
possibilité d'apprendre à leur rythme
s'il y avait plus de bienveillance je
vous invite à travailler dessus
je pense qu'on aurait déjà trouvé
beaucoup plus de solutions la
bienveillance que mon apprises les
abeilles c'est un respect mutuel il peut
y avoir la confrontation
et on continue en coaching on dit
qu'elle est très utile pourquoi parce
que la confrontation amène à la prise de
conscience prise de conscience a même
éventuellement à une prise d'actions
d'accord pour la prise d'actions et pour
votre décision vous êtes seul
responsable c'est pour ça que je le
disais il est important de ne pas se
laisser se dit et ce qu'on a à faire
seul responsable face à notre santé seul
responsable face à nos choix à
l'évolution notre carrière à notre
implication dans une vie associative
seul responsable
je vais vous demander un petit exercice
qui implique tout le monde ici alors je
me blesse parce que je vois je vois pas
beaucoup ce que je peux vous demander de
vous lever tous
s'il vous plaît
je vous demandais de faire quelque chose
je crois qui a jamais été fait dans une
conférence ted
je vous demander de vous donner la main
vous pouvez faire la ola si vous voulez
vous sentez tout d'un coup cette énergie
vous avez sans doute des problèmes
vous avez peut-être vécu des problèmes
de santé vous en avez peut-être vu
devant vous dans votre entourage
ces maladies de civilisation qui nous
touche de plus en plus et peut-être
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une personne dans
cette salle qui peut vous aider
peut-être qu'il ya une personne dans
cette salle qui peut vous indiquer qu'un
d'autres donc ma conclusion ici c'est à
dire oui vous êtes seul responsable mais
on n'est pas tout seul merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]